et en direct dans ce gîte et ludovic de
lahej expert en communication et auteur
d'un documentaire sur les retraites
intitulé retraite les insoumis mène la
lutte à l'assemblée bonjour ludovic de
la herse merci de répondre à nos
questions en fin de non-recevoir unanime
donc face à la relance du dossier
sensible de la réforme des retraites
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter ce
premier rendez vous entre les
partenaires sociaux et le nouveau
premier ministre en séminaire
gouvernemental ce matin d'après moi ce
premier rendez vous et ceux qui vont
suivre sont une suite organisé d'actes
de communication parce que on avait un
président qui pendant le confinement et
la crise sanitaire nous expliquer que
cette réforme des retraites était une
erreur que de l'amener au pas de charge
était une erreur dont il est chargé le
déjà le dos d'edouard philippe avant de
le virer
et là on reçoit des syndicats qui sont
tous pour une fois unanimes pour dire
qu'il y avait dans cette réforme de
retraites n'a aucun sens mais elle sera
faite quand même enfin en tout cas ils
vont essayer parce qu'elle fait partie
du cahier des charges des manuels macro
arrivée à la présidence des gens ont
financé sa campagne et en contrepartie
il doit privatiser le système des
retraites et pour ça il faut faire cette
première réforme et qui permet ensuite
de prévu et privatisé plus globalement
la sécurité sociale c'est réforme des
retraites depuis le départ n'est pas
nécessaire il faut rappeler plusieurs
choses
1 le système des retraites est
bénéficiaire de plus de 8 milliards
ensuite on veut faire une réforme basée
sur des anticipations fait dont on n'est
absolument pas certain qu'ils annoncent
à partir de 2025 ou 2040 un système de
retraite déficitaire sauf que en fait
personne et la corée qui chiffre là on
n'est même pas sûr qu'elle soit
déficitaire et enfin on a quand même la
kadey ce qui était prévu par lionel
jospin qui va arriver à échéance dans
deux ans qui va renflouer à nouveau ce
système des retraites les régimes
spéciaux sont équilibrés cette réforme
n'a aucun lieu d'être et donc l'art
c'est un acte de communication pure pour
dire on a négocié avec les syndicats
on a essayé de parler avec eux bon ben
on n'arrive pas à s'entendre on va quand
même faire valoir réforme parce que nous
savons et vous ne savez pas vous n'est
pas responsable
et puis si jamais il ya une grogne
sociale et puis un soulèvement un des
syndicats qui appellent à manifester
dirar confinement voilà au moins vous
parlez de grandes social à emmanuel
macron a évoqué une rentrée qui se
compliqué quelle marge de manoeuvre pour
jean castex pour qu'elle ne soit pas
apocalyptique la marge brute est pour le
moins capex allait elle et elle est
extrêmement large
en réalité il vaut ça en parlait hier
ils vont re confiné l'île de france
donc il n'y aura pas de possibilité de
se mettre dans la rue pour manifester
son mécontentement
ils ont complètement verrouillé
l'assemblée depuis le départ et jean
castex est pas un inconnu
beaucoup l'ont été que comme un inconnu
c'était le bleu le haut fonctionnaire le
mieux payé de toute la vème république
et qui applique parfaitement les ordres
donc il va appliquer parfaitement
désordre il ira en force comme depuis le
départ de ce quinquennat
mais sauf que là il y en a une crise
sanitaire qui fait que la législation
n'est pas tout à fait la même on n'a pas
droit de se réunir on apparaître des
filets de manifester sans autorisation
vous savez là il doit philippe a été
viré il me semble qu'ils aient quand
même plutôt du bon boulot pour appliquer
une politique de droite et qu'il était
assez droit et intègre alors que par
contre le préfet l'allemand et a
présenté sa démission a été acceptée par
le président de la république alors que
le préfet l'allemand lui toujours en
place alors qu'on a des vrais problèmes
qui sont déroulés si l'allemand est
toujours en place ce qu'il veut a besoin
de réprimer effectivement un
mécontentement social
parce que cette réforme de retraites
enfin elle est ubuesque de toute façon
depuis le départ est sa seule raison
d'être c'est d'imposer le système par
points donc là jean castex vient aux
responsabilités pour appliquer ce que
emmanuel macron a promis de faire dès le
début de son quinquennat aux gens qui
n'ont financé donc il faut absolument
aboutir cette réforme qui n'est pas en
soi une privatisation
la retraite mais c'est la première étape
nécessaire pour pouvoir le faire ensuite
pour passer système par points et
ensuite de faire une privatisation de la
sécurité sociale dans son ensemble
donc c'est la libération des non pas des
énergies mais des marchés pour les
grandes entreprises d'assurances et 2 et
de maladies
donc là ils vont ils vont y aller c'est
certain et le gouvernement qui était
mise en place de ce sont à l'air calibré
pour appliquer de façon ce qui était
dans la feuille de route des manuels
macron et avec des gens qui connaissent
un petit peu les rouages du congo ritual
un très bon exemple on voit actuellement
l'image
roselyne bachelot pareils sont des gens
qui connaissent très bien les rouages
bleus
cage possible donc il a pris des gens
dans ce gouvernement
jean castex pour pouvoir lui débloquer
tous les rouages qui permettrait de
bloquer les réformes qui sont là prêts
emmanuel macron nécessaire alors qu'on
sait que vous le disiez à la rentrée
sera dur grégory il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont ils vont beaucoup souffrir
on va rajouter une réforme par dessus
qui va appauvrir les plus pour en france
qui vont déjà subir cette crise
sanitaire de plein fouet et toutes les
petites entreprises vont se retrouver
encore plus fragilisée par cette réforme
des retraites donc enfin ça n'a aucun
sens en réalité ça n'a aucun sens si on
aurait pu croire que ces crises
sanitaires ramènerait à la raison eh
bien non froidement il déroule le
programme qui prévu et qui n'a pas été
présenté d'ailleurs parce qu'il sort
était de bon ton de le mettre en
campagne électorale le dit à qui voulait
privatiser le système des retraites en
faire un système par points et
privatiser la sécurité sociale sap a été
annoncée ce sera fait donc là on arrive
on va voir pas numéro d'opérette en fait
qu'ils vont ils vont s'enchaîner pour
pouvoir justifier ses décisions
merci le 2 mai calado l'air d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en communication et
auteur d'un documentaire sur les
retraites